how's it going there soldiers of the
reject Battalion we are here it's John
and Andrew Gordon today to check out the
aircut of Suicide Squad AKA 2014's Fury
how you doing man you excited I'm good
you ruined the punchline of my not so
funny joke I was going to say I was
going to ask no no no it's fine I was
going to ask are we watching the
theatrical cut or is this the aircut I
was just curious I don't know but I
guess we're going to find out you are
going to find out and hey either way
before we jump into this just comment
below do you want to see the aircut as I
do leave your thoughts down
below like for director's Visions being
un mangled when they get to us uh don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you can get
notified every time one of these videos
comes your way as well thank you to the
fine folks at prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights it is a task
we appreciate them dearly for it and if
you guys want to get the complete Fury
experience alongside Andrew and myself
grab your own copy bring it over to
patreon.com theal Rejects and sync up
with us you can enjoy the movie front
and back as well as all the other things
we have streaming over there with
highlights and watch alongs included
it's a blast people it's a good time and
uh speaking of time it is now time to
jump in this movie are you ready Andrew
sir yes sir roll out
out the woods they for
tank love a good bit of radio chatter
World War World War II American tanks
were outgunned and out armored by the
more advanced charman
tanks us tank crewman suffered
staggering losses against the superior
enemy
Vehicles woo woo woo interesting the
aircut the Allies fight deep in the
heart of Nazi Germany encountering the
most fanatical resistance yet in
desperation Hitler declares Total War
mobilizing every man woman and
child a casual stroll over no man's land
it's the reverse ending of
Shane coming back into town
[Music]
do appreciate a striking and patient
opening
shot my warhorse
damn
jeez like a literally a Boneyard made of
Tanks oh jeez
whoa damn what an
entrance jeez and great perspective
shift too I was just thinking we don't
even know what side this guy's on
yet God and the Pale Horse Too face to
face with
[Music]
symbolism how long you been chilling
down there I going to say that was not
only an impressive but impressive that
he survived that ensuing battle before
too
sure everyone's favorite character for
man man it' be nice to see him in a
drama again yeah yeah Michael PNE is a
great actor oh he is Crash was the first
movie I ever saw him in you get that I
knocked him off and then I killed the
[__] out of him stab the [__] out of
him whoa what's going on there Shia
lordo stop leave him rest he's dead show
some respect leave him alone yeah just
leave him it's your fault God damn it
ain't you done yet you got no right to
be SW me quit ride me or where he came
from you do you f we here oh that is
John Bernthal you you didn't recognize
him I thought it looked like him but
yeah I was about to say it but I figured
you'd recognized him I said why you
always whooping on me cuz you're an
animal dog all you understand is the
Fist and boot I'm telling you right
now you keep talking [__] to me I'm
going to punish
you hey you want to talk Mexican join
another tank this American tank we talk
American and I want my scals you talk
German I can't talk Spanish what country
are we in Germany Germany they speak
German we go to Mexico we'll talk
Mexican I expect all of you to pull your
[__] together and I want my [__] should
stop ring on everyone you kill R Germans
did that is true but I didn't save him
either his number came up that's all we
been lucky to now been lucky
we're all alive we're in here God's
grace luck has nothing to do with
this really good job of establishing
like who these guys are and their
interactions are so good and a nice
contrast from all the silence to start
with yeah and just immediate bickering
rain's
coming couldn't ask anytime sweetheart
I'm a sweetheart right jeez
CH her up she's cold there's
condensation on the pl oh boy God these
guys must had to spend so much time in
close quarters to prep for this yeah I
was kind of I was just thinking
that
gun jeez oh collection I like it yeah
your War trophies those evil miserable
Leeps good cut jeez abrupt appropriate
cut like
it subverting our expectations in that
moment the fury some really impressive
cinematography so
[Music]
far wow yep yep I wasn't thinking about
it but but I feel like yeah if anybody's
going to show us like some of those
nasty little like casual nuances of the
Fallout of war is going to be David a
[Music]
yeah wonder where they shot
this yeah I know where they shot this is
in the mud
true y steady yourself thought you were
dead sorry to
disappoint flame down flame down move
Jesus oh yeah careful boys Sergeant
where's the rest of third
platoon you're looking at him we're
it tag we got a job to do restock ammo
and rations Gordo water and gas boys get
some chow and do what you can about the
mechanical issues we can't do [__] about
mechanical issues where you going to not
mourn some
more or yeah maybe just going yeah let
it out right here
got to stay strong for his men yeah oh
dude yeah buddy don't want to tear down
team
morale damn just like the scarring on
his face yeah yeah you can tell just
from that how much battles he been
through oh I don't like the choice to
have it just be a sound CU like I
thought we were going to cut to
something but not just like playing it
in his face for sergeant caller maybe
with you private I was told to report to
you I'm your new assistant driver oh is
that Percy Jackson OH Logan lurman no
you are
not who told you this master sergeant
with the clipboard [__] right there
he's oh what's your name Norman Osborne
yes definitely how long you been in the
Army 10 days 8 weeks you're were close
that's home do as you're told don't get
too close to anyone you're the new red
no pressure hi I'm
Norman oh no damn he's like way out of
his element right now with these guys I
love it well no one's ready to receive
him which way is the front which way is
the
front all around us kid cuz this Germany
we're surrounded by crows that right
great that's
right don't read my diary can I please
have my book back we your cigarettes I
don't smoke now you do he you go to tank
School cool no never even seen the
inside of a tank oh that's comforting
was heading to fifth core HQ they pulled
me off the truck they sent me here oh
wow that's how much they value your
lives are you a praying man I go to
church what kind of Bible you got who's
your nomination are you pellion yeah you
are you're the main liner ain't you I am
are you saved oh I'm baptized that ain't
what I what he
ass dude he's going to have to harden up
to hang with these guys no they're going
to soft up to his level oh definitely
wait until you see see what what a man
can do to another man true that this is
an interesting choice in the score to
have it like a heartbeat too get a
bucket of hot water from the kitchen get
that [__] clean oh yeah Red's still
probably all over
it it's a fascinating eyeline too the
most out of your element for us to
relate
through
W are
we
guy yeah how much time in the Army is
just spent scrubbing that's a good
question that's why they're so strong
just wow my
God
jeez props to the special effects team
though that's uh quite convincingly real
oh he's not going to sleep right ever
again throw up yeah I I would probably
be doing the same thing oh
yeah
oh I think he's ready to go out into the
field I have a feeling we are about to
see a war movie that sort of redefines
what Gore in war movies looks like like
I feel like war movies already introduce
you to the kinds of Carnage you wouldn't
normally see and other more pulpy things
but especially here like with that face
bit like de gloved elements like
G I imagine we're going to see some [__]
hey why you bringing him through here
why isn't he sleeping G2 wants a
prisoner to question sure B stand's
father shy thick of
VI oh oh yeah jeez do it do it do it you
have my
permission Jesus you see that he's an SS
you kill every last one you can the real
[__] sure done much killing no you
will what do I do with
this see that cover yeah open it now you
killing close it
up main unit's punching East we are
going north we tie up with Baker company
from the 41st Sergeant CER is with us
now he'll be acting platoon Sergeant God
man this guy is so fresh faed by
comparison we're meeting Baker company
here then together we'll take this town
after that we're working for Captain
Wagner I got one question sure
Peterson I'm bowsky sir get it right you
start shaving your
face the dialogue is so good so far yeah
hey Daddy is too hot
jeez got to have something to laugh
about I love how quick he is
you are in German an wow Germany an
enemy country oh my
god
wow saddens my heart all right there
might be a wolf hiding in the Sheep get
you're up cast an eyeball on anything
that makes a move you cut them right in
half yeah wow problem you do what you
got to do copy I copy H is he going to
hesitate hey guns ready just pull the
trigger every five round to the Tracer
so you can see what you're hitting and
remember short burst that way you
harvest more meat poor bullet O wowe A
tracer
[Music]
huh this is doing a very nice job of
highlighting that this is just miserable
for
everyone should let you for a chocolate
bar not true okay it's not true
completely true dud we'll just give her
some smokes ain't got to [__] around
give her a whole pack
neither disappoint Christ now don't let
them lead you straight sure be a
faithful man trt
your Jesus loves Hitler Hitler said to
Jesus in his heart got baptized he be
saved what about your regular TR I'm not
going to do this for going to heav we've
been talking about the same dumb [__]
for 3 years you know I'll stand on it
trying to me up now but for us the
audience sing me him yeah sure sing Old
R sing I'll sing it if you don't do that
your
mustach let me touch your this is what
John does to me all the time let me
touch it it's actually is very
satisfying you think us for cholate
bar I mean rumor has it he
might this is also
capturing the slowness of travel oh oh
oh damn that is like a
rocket yeah yeah
yeah ah got
him wow
damn oh my
God just becomes an
oven father dude stay focused bro I feel
you stay
focused yeah
that's
scary oh jesz why did you take the shot
he was just a kid I'm sorry I'm really
sorry Sergeant oh this is lesson one
look that's your
fault next German you see with a weapon
you wre the dog [__] out I don't care if
it's a baby with a butter knife in one
hand M the you Cho him off
[Music]
Sergeant all tanks War daddy looks like
I'm it
tag I'll leave the column let's get us
where we're
going and on we go the cycle hums yes
sir I'm not a sir me neither oh who's in
charge of this column I am hey oh Scott
Eastwood yeah Scot one park it over
there old man's waiting a and then a
worked with him again in uh everyone's
favorite comic book film you know maybe
they can get together for a third
collab out pushing mother you do Lo the
casualties into a truck hey Jason ISAC
oh is that him damn all right how many
Texs we got four four or you could say
lucious Maloy his American accent is
actually convince convincing all right
here's the deal I got platoon trapped in
this beat fi by machine guns I sent my
tracks in Jerry took him out wowe and
Titanic guns there there possibly there
I don't know I need you to rescue my guy
I think this is the first time I've
heard him with this accent yeah I've
never heard him with an American accent
either this High Ground you got any eyes
on it I had eyes there gone there gone
we Flying Blind you and me it's all
about that High Ground you can ride
Magic car for I care I know you know
what you're doing you just Pac them hard
for me they murder some good boys out
there today yeah and every day let's get
these boys out of there and smash those
guns why are we rescuing kittens instead
of just driving down to Berlin why are
you such an
[__] March order Fury old Phyllis
Lucy Sue murder
ink God what
names I think he's ready for this one
this time yeah good old Norman he's
getting there God willing he will be
hardened by the end of the film
unfortunately all right let's get the
boys off get them off give me last man
all right
[Applause]
Chiefs Dam those D look freaking
heavy right there hold yeah some's
waiting yeah it's our trap well it's a
rescue I guess
right dude so much tension yeah one just
like the constant chatter too yeah yeah
yeah all right let's go up if I say hold
back hold back
God
oh Nikes
what damn like green what is that
they're going so fast that's why they
look like
that
[Music]
wow
jeez
fire
wow nice
H left
jeez
damn wow that's one way to Deforest the
tree
line up every come on Norman be the
hero
God every every shot every blast like
you feel it yeah all tank start
squirting that tree line let's light him
up starts squirting that tree
wow it's interesting the color of the
the flashes where do I shoot at the
Nazis
D that's a good
idea got to
reload yeah boy throwing him in the TR
on the
first
got
wa don't what you're here for I was
loading the gun yeah faster
is escort those squats on the left
see oh I see our dead bodies how do you
know they're dead are you a
doctor why would I shoot them if they're
already dead it's called the double tap
do it don't stand up for soon than
yeah
here oh
dude give up oh man oh this ain't pretty
you know this what we do damn yeah I
mean this is just a first day but I get
it I would fold pretty quickly too
probably I mean yeah we we would all
have to this is just a threshold that I
imagine anybody who makes it far enough
gets
to First time you see real action I can
only imagine I mean we're just watching
it on a nice HD TV and it's pretty crazy
zero perspective of our own yeah so
imagine if you're actually there it's
I'm assuming it's 50,000 times
worse
oh no moment to breathe yeah I promised
my crew a long time ago I'd keep them
alive you're getting in the way of
that okay I'm trained to type 60 words a
minute I am not trained to machine gun
dead bodies I'm trying my very best sure
man I like that choice of uh Brad Pitt's
character there with quivering his lip
there that was a good choice oh yeah he
he's being tough on this dude cuz he has
to be yeah and he knows how harsh it is
that he has to be course he can
sympathize but also at the same time
he's got to look out for his crew I get
it get out here oh he going to have you
do it
Norman come here oh yep here it comes I
mean he did get a kill earlier with the
machine gun but actually to have him do
a close combat one yeah not even combat
he just needs to do an execution yeah he
needs to harden Harden him
up your
dog yeah because you were so concerned
for other people's families and children
too so yeah we should sympathize with
you you a't no goddamn good to me unless
you can kill Crow put a big fat hole in
his back no why the hell not it's not
right we're not here for right and wrong
we're here to kill them she you know why
he's here well to kill you he's here to
kill you he's here to rip your
throat we're already in hell trying to
teach you something I need you to
perform get over with I can't do it yes
you can you are him pick kill me yeah
kill me kill kill me kill
me
wow oh my God just the easy
part yeah H he's going to for yeah do it
Norman your
job where
you out we've all been you kid or at
least many of us sure some people out
there had no hesitation which is also
scary I like how much of this is being
communicated through expression and
Silent moments in between like the
dialogue is only ever half of it we've
been together since before Africa I
won't fight with anybody else me neither
but ain't no Crusade together like we
have nor that's because of him we love
him we love him down North Africa Don he
done [__] his George full he stunk tank
up real life it's true
oh oh no what are y'all talking about
over here Norman I haven't seen you eat
anything all day make sure you get
something to eat he is like the
emotionally reserved repressed dad he B
go eat something and these are just the
brothers make sure he sees it to yeah I
mean they're hand hands are in I mean
their lives are in his hands so they got
to toughen him up I get it it's both
yeah it's like for their sakes and if
he's going to be here you know for
his wow what a great cinematic
shot wowe there you go boys keep
pounding impressive Tom Hardy's up there
somewhere I understood that reference
and Christopher Nolan's up there with
them right oh always I got to rewatch
that one it's it's been a while
oh poor poor war
[Music]
horses something children what are them
s say I'm a coward and refuse to fight
from the German people wow wow the SS
does that let him rip to Pieces huh now
you got to go into ation Norman put they
doubt up
p and that one shot too where they ran
over that one
soldier sh back I got you
D and we are just traveling in real time
too or what mostly feels like real
time just punch through that wall of
smoke okay hard left 9:00 9:00 oh boy oh
boy this must have been a wild
experience to
shoot my God
Jesus
damn
woo white scared the B Jesus out of
me
yeah come on Mo up where's Berry pepper
right now up in the bell tower I have
not seen it's Saving Private Ryan I
assume you're talking about I've not
seen it wow wow that's to the list boy
come on keep moving up that door that
doorway is that Scot
Scot jeez on my left giv him what for
slap him around a little bit for
you I'm assuming the violence in Saving
priv Ryan is around this level well
that's what I'm saying is is it it is
violent and in ways you're not used to
but this is going even further in that
direction in terms of just like stuff
you're not seeing bodies do when being
rended wow wish I could read some of
that German I
yeah no wiie Pete in that ground
floor Willie Pete
ready wow I don't realize how many
things have a foot
trigger
a they
cooking yeah let them
suffer hey Norman
yeah mercy killing stacking him up you
should have let him burn he's being
accepted by the group but he's still
rebelling way oh no of course of course
understandably so that's a yeah that's a
character
beat here waving the White
Flag you and get ready to put in that
bank if these people want to test check
the door check the
door oh God it's a bunch of
kids D but they were forc I mean I'm not
a green but they were forced to do it
you saw what happens when they don't do
it shoot that guy this guy yeah him he
has said with the busted Wing
sure
oh
yeah quick but brutal good squibs too oh
yeah what are you doing I'm I'm I'm
going take care of you okay he he gave
her a chocolate bar right before that
that's true he's got a whole bag full
going up
there jeez
[Music]
dude he going to give her a little TLC
John tender caring they're just going to
talk man he just wants to get to know
her it's their first date Andrew uhhuh
Norman wasn't nothing right open out
those hinies you flashing real good
wasn't nothing right sure
Sergeant yeah it wasn't nothing kind of
like
wow did did you though the communication
happening between their eyes versus what
they're saying it's fascinating
it's like there's a double speak you
have to adopt and you're all kind of
aware that this isn't good for your soul
but they knew we were coming so they got
drunk as Lords and they shot themselves
a son up burn that portrait why are you
showing me this ideals are peaceful
history is violent bars if only we could
get to a peaceful history say vigio
mortson would agree Vigo sorry I still
haven't seen that one either every vgo
mortensson movie every single one no
what I tell you you do that you make get
through this
thing sir yes sir come
on oh
no
oh speak some German we want to
here it's probably the first word you
learned
peace think she has a a child there or
her husband I don't know husband or
child John which one or like a a refugee
throw us a real
curveball come
C oh
oh
jeez s keeps pushing her around by the
chest make me a sandwich but in
German
Emma you have an Emma in your
life
what huh oh hard bow legs
yeah cigarettes I was about to say is he
going to offer cigarettes just gave him
two full packs it's like a $100 in back
then military cigarette exchange
currency
oh it's how you win your way to a
woman's heart either poetry or playing
the piano or taking your shirt off or
having abs like that that works
too huh hard a flutter he points the gun
at me and he plays the
[Music]
piano I'm so afraid I'm about to rip
this moment apart I know thinking
that
whoa damn he's been through it and that
is not what I
expected such a great shot damn she's a
good clean girl you don't take her in
that bedroom I
will good
advice jeez know she'll make a man out
of
you wowe
nine this isn't nice moment though for
us to catch our breath a little from the
battle this is the first true moment of
a breather that truly feels like one and
I think that's a smart we're like What
like an hour in it's like that's a smart
choice actually cuz even the lowkey
moments have been fraught with stress
and anger and all sorts of other things
can I see your hand you can tell a lot
about a person from the lines on their
hand you study palmistry dides she speak
speak English that is your
heartline you are going to have one
great love in your life oh
my I think she understood that
yep interesting moment of
hesitation was very
intimate God there
those doors ain't that
thick can we have some
privacy it's a good Commander you hooked
him up how much time has passed here
it's been at least 5 minutes and 30
seconds you like crabby patties don't
you Squidward oh my God you guys played
a board
game
Oh I thought that was a battle about to
start oh no
Norman come for you to act a
man he special gas she down there she
waiting on you oh no yeah she looks a
little bit like
but oh my God SN what did you do ug did
you God and the tension like on hers
young
for you do that what's what's with your
lip what with your lip why qu do not
touch her come on man but no touch it me
what to do you think you get act like a
man anyone touches a girl to get their
teeth kicked in sir yes sir I like like
how honorable he is all right then I
guess it's Norman day huh the beach is
at Norman day just ruined the whole mood
you best take by you man right drink it
at least give him a
chaser touch me don't touch you a man
right man right god dude how about I
kill you right
here the literal opposite character I
don't know they kind of acting the same
to me yeah my bad I don't know which one
to shoot we love you dear Lord thank you
for this meal this wonderful company
amen amen amen amen wonderful company
Emma offer the grer
plate even you even Bible
guy that for you oh for you real
quick dude
[Music]
really God this is like the most
horrific hazing I'm join my meal boys
and as much much as you want to destroy
it you're not going to stop me no
sir and Norman do you like horses not if
not if any of you guys are asking Don
likes horses and I right down we're
eating no we're not I'm done I'm done e
crying he's always crying and France we
hit the beach right after d day we had
to fight through all these hedge rolls
pain in the ass right finally hit Open
Country and we linked up with the
British and the Canadians you know what
we did we trapped an entire crowd Army
pulling back into Germany took them out
W them up there was dead cruts and
horses busted up tanks for
miles kilometers your I see it but your
head can't make no sense of it and we go
in there it's poor woman for three whole
days we shoot that wounded
horses jeez do you know how you kill a
horse p on the forehead and it becomes
your f it goes like this we Sho it Jesus
right through the spine oh all the black
clouds of flies just bugging around like
being in a in a giant beeh high with The
Beekeeper that's a good reference there
John it's my movie you're talking about
A Real Fine story Pleasant Meal Time
talk thank
you what happened happen what's going to
happen is going to happen sitting here
playing house a couple [__] crowds
ain't going to change shut up why should
I shut
up wow the old man one how come you got
a mission I would not leave those guys
up there yeah exactly
yeah next name next
next a she likes him get married y doing
dude I hope they get to see each other
again Italian needs you to guard these
Crossroads here and this grid on the
open they have tanks horses artillery
all the above all the tanks are driving
on Berlin a couple of thousand Cooks
mechanics and doctors here those crows
hit him it'll be a Slaughter yeah all we
got is
you jeez need you to Crossroad as fast
as you can don't stop for anything
understand take my gas you have those
troops get past you it's
over oh my
God whoa oh I hope those two women are
okay I was going to say was that the
building they were just in I was just
thinking
that
just always that name painted on the
barrel good and framed right next to a a
musical horn
jeez
[Music]
yeah yeah God damn it oh
crap oh how cruel oh no oh my god dude
under the piano and everything
no oh you're the last person kill him
kill
[Music]
him come
on war
[Applause]
[Music]
feel thank you are wow damn I guess he
has a point but also yeah but if he
wasn't being so cold and heartless
before when they were with her I mean
[Music]
yeah oh he knows that look I do love
seeing this vulnerable side of uh Brad
Pit's character too really appreciate it
you see that that's an entire city on
fire I started this war killing Germans
in Africa then France then Belgium now
I'm killing Germans in Germany but all
burning cities look the same it will end
soon but before it does a lot more
people got to
die I can understand now why PTSD is
such a real thing oh I mean
absolutely I mean seems like you you
spent 10 minutes in place like
this left
left go go go go go oh goddamn
tiger face let's go smoke up
on
yeah goli on its ass hit that son of a
[__] go go
go
shoot stop stop stop stop that's what I
was saying it looked like they were
about to head
trees what do we
[Music]
got
oh guttural
vocal
charge
again come
on
oh it's that tiny little
slot that dude just just turned into a
cloud of
[Music]
red
oo they got Peterson yeah Davis is
lining up
fire shoot the son of a [__] he's up on
Roy oh my
[Music]
god
wow
D it really is going to be down to just
you we're on this left up to us now get
around put us on back side oh my
God how many other like predominantly
tank based war movies are there I just
realized we've had so many of these tank
fights and now we're literally just
doing like a tank melee you got out that
this is
intense jeez
dude wow come
[Music]
on
oh not
bad
oh yeah they coming out
now oh oh
get him
Norman oh
[Music]
Norman he has oh after what he just
witnessed to they did to his
woman yeah he's changing he's not he's
not going to hesitate anymore he's to
some degree engaging in that bloodlust
that
Fury hey good job nor welcome to the
Army nor you did good
oh he's a part of the
team best I've ever had that's the way
you got to cope and convince yourself of
[__] oh yeah let's head out those
Crossroads keep it out of Crouch hands
like we've been told there's a wave
coming in where the rock to break that
wave what did we say about the Spanish
in the tank he said it was okay right
it' be whatever the German equivalent is
all right there's a Crossroads we don't
take us up on that hill we can cover the
whole Valley from there there's a demon
up there we can make a
[Music]
deal
oh Jesus like a mine oh oh my
crap settle down it's a mine we hit a
mine is all is all I have been jump
scared quite a few times in this film I
mean it speaks to the disconcertion and
how anything can rip through the room at
any time true Norman you and C house
check out that building my
TOs
oh oh Hospital Wing yeah was this like
an old medical Barracks I think you're a
good man I think maybe we ain't but I
think you
are want to tell you that it's okay
let's go I appreciate that dialogue head
up top of that Hill near those trees you
got Outpost guard can I grab my canteen
yeah you can grab your
canteen stop at Hill and work your way
from the trees going to be like a
predator out here yeah cake yourself in
mud it's probably real easy to stay in
character like the way it's shot and
then with all the action sequences Oh
Yeah from top to bottom just like
figuring out how to make something like
this happen yeah I've been marveling
like every
[Music]
scene oh
no yeah crap get out there get down
there he that shot looking through the
leaves just like the lens the L the
glass like the way you can kind of feel
the glass on some of these
shots going to have a little repeat of
uh your previous Battalion Massacre slow
down they're coming right now who's
coming Germans how many two maybe 300 of
them they got vehicles too tanks no no
no Just Trucks point the tanks at the
trucks fire away goddamn SS Battalion
let just get our [__] all right look
it's about to be dark just on up out of
here huh oh we're staying in our tank
we're going to fight it out we can't I'm
going to hold this Crossroad what you
mean going to hold this the Tank's
busted what's your point well we ain't
got a tank how we going to fight we got
a cannon that don't make
sense you got a Death Wish sir get out
of here get to that tree
line Oh Captain My Captain take care of
yourselves get to that tree line oh no
no no guys you got to stay with him them
now come on yeah help Dad this my
home staying here with
you damn we're going to
stay I love the way that they play with
what is you playing the real struggle of
being a a team a battalion and the
leadership involved with that they don't
just all just trust him completely
implicitly it's not like they never
mouth off like oh it humanizes the
characters too as well not just going to
Blind follow orders well yeah and like
in a moment like that I'm like I don't
know half of them could have just like
you know I bet they probably won't but
half of them could have just walked
right off well I mean too when I say
blindly followers I mean at the same
time he said go on get out of there go
to that tree line that's what that's
what I'm saying though is I'm not as
used to seeing that where it's like they
clearly have a huge amount of trust in
this guy but not so much that there
aren't times where you're like this
could all fall apart right now you
know
[Music]
oh wow ah May the odds be ever in your
favor
sure bless it what you going to do with
that I'm going to drink it holy fire
water you know's Bible verse I think
about sometimes many times it goes then
I heard the voice of the Lord saying
whom shall I send and who will go for us
oh I said here am I send
me dang Isaiah 6 knowing how committed
child La buff is I'm sure in real life
he learned the whole Bible I'm thinking
he pulled that tooth out for real like
you f drank a machine ain't you machine
that's it that's his War
name I Chis in the
machine damn dude ma machine machine
machine
that's what she got to be I
guess that is a
lot it's an interesting
gesture
[Music]
oh
hey yeah fire on one
[Music]
oh wow put in that building
full give me another that was beautiful
you
away
[Music]
damn mer
left will
whoa what a shot sh
[Music]
one
reload we out we out oh no rure gun is G
yeah we got 30 on the roof all right we
got ammo outside
jeez and it looks completely like it
looks like hell outside now
go yeah felt that line through my soul
boy oh boy come on
man
yep I think they'll let that one
slide click click click yeah yep oh no
no
[Applause]
yeah D sure ain't no good leak can roll
everywhere catch me up then you're hurt
you're bleeding I got time to bleed if a
man loves the world love of the father's
not in him all it's in the world lust of
the flesh lust of the eyes pride of
life it's not the father to the world
his desires pass away but he who does
God's will is going to live forever
forever interesting it's fascinating to
see them like cope with the godlessness
of what they're doing
with faith or at least the kind of
communal thing that you can turn faith
into can be damn sure they're working
the way behind us anybody see anything I
see nothing nothing
nothing damn they coming B
4:00 oh [__] wow he missed hit with
the w
w yeah that'll do it oh crap [__] who
got
[Music]
hit
oh get up still in this fight
yeah this chapter of Fury is called
despair how long can we keep this up as
long as it takes yeah I'm out I need a
new can that's the last belt she's on
it's all there
is yeah don't get your panties in the
bunch we still got hand weapons in the
50 that's the spirit where the hell are
are they they're everywhere what are
they like fan way out
oh turning NE into
stumps yeah go I need
aapon oh crap oh crap oh
[Music]
crap
yeah no no oh hold on to that
thing oh no oh my God
buddy without hesitation
oh oh man oh
no hey come
on damn dude you weren't lying when they
said they needed
mud
H yeah keep running your
mouth oh damn epic badass line
oh
God Bible where you
at
B and then there were
two oh no
no
[Music]
no come on get him Logan lurman
machine oh damn it
man oh
no button
up oh jeez I'm sorry
Sean okay what can any of us do did my
best wonder if they were in the tank
together for this moment like shooting
Sant go here yes I'm
scared needs his leader I'm scared
too
oh what a
moment I want to surrender please don't
yeah they'll hurt you real bad and
they'll kill you real bad yeah true what
I do fight there's a hatch okay you see
it I see it I know where it is I know
where it
is
[Music]
oh oh no crap yeah get in the hatch
go
yeah burrow yourself in I
guess oh Jesus
[Music]
Christ oh jeez so much in his
eyes
interesting wow maybe he's the mirrored
version of him on that side could be I
mean so much of this movie I've been
thinking like just how much of the same
movie is happening on the other side
yeah God just the color contrast now
complete opposite from hell to this
orange to Blue tungsten to
Daylight
wow I could tell you if this would have
happened earlier in the film when they
first met wouldn't have had this level
of respect and love for him like he does
now oh no not not not at
all that like protected him through the
whole experience yeah in ways that he
never could have realized day one even
though this is like day two yeah yeah
but I mean if
it felt longer than what you're what
you're saying but yes from the jump yeah
so many event things happened in that
one or two days that it felt so much
longer than that whose face is on the
handle of his gun was that maybe his why
or something I don't
know is is this going to be us Americans
yeah
ah easy boy easy now we're on the same
side and ain't never going to let go of
that gun yeah this dude is going to have
severe
PTSD hey you were hero
buddy I mean he is though he is no I'm
not laughing at I don't think he's
cowardly in any way no the the loaded
nature of that sentiment
in that
moment like there's so many
layers and now we're just moving away
now we're just moving
on and just like what a great
contrasting end shot like a nice book
end well we started off on that slow
shot coming up with the horse and then
yeah exactly to this waiting for some to
pop out the tank now we're just staring
down at it
all ascending to the heavens essentially
as the whole thing's buttoned up yeah
release the
aircut wow man by the way if you guys
are listening to us on Apple or Spotify
if you would not mind rating us we
really would appreciate it I know jonald
and myself would please so much thank
you so much uh now really oh Brad Pit
produced it cool that makes sense um now
really really heartfelt film I
appreciated David uh A's gritty style of
directing and writing too I mean look
the action sequences and the
cinematography I mean I I can't is this
real footage I would assume this looks
like authentic
footage yeah I assume continue but but
yeah no I I was just saying like I
appreciated David A's uh gritty style of
film making from the action sequences
and uh the cinematography like and also
too I I truly appreciated just you know
I always talk about this when we're in
uh period pieces like really getting the
feel of uh that we're in that time and
feeling like we're there uh but I think
the thing uh that I appreciated the most
in this was the camaraderie between the
team the dialogue the interactions it
was so good and I like that things were
not always so black and white and what I
mean by that is yeah they were for the
most part they were good guys but there
were also times where they were well I
mean I mean but also too there were
times where they were they could be
pieces of shits too that's what say like
when we got to I think you good guy is a
very dubious say things were not always
black and white like I'm saying when we
got to the scene after Logan lurman had
had you know become a man if you will
and then we get to see John Bernthal
when he in a drunk State of
Mind was not a very good human being
there in any way shape or form even
though we were on I mean even when he
wasn't drunk most of the time yeah no no
no of course but I did but there was
that scene that really humanized him
when they were in the hospital wing and
him and Logan lurman talked I was like
like okay I'm I appreciate John
bernthal's performance I haven't been on
this character's side the whole time at
all really um but I do appreciate this
interaction we're getting it's kind of
humanizing the character just a little
bit even though I know he's been through
hell and back and I can only imagine
psychologically what that does to
someone well yeah it's that it's that
Ray of humanity that for a character
like that especially I mean you have to
wonder like okay this guy's seen the
horrors of War obviously but like what
else was this dude's life like that you
know it's like what are all the layers
of of who this guy is and I have to
believe that you know it's that Nuance
of like there's Humanity in this person
and here's a glimpse of it uh but you
know it's it's yeah it's part of this
gray portrait of who he is and by
extension who all these people
are and uh and yeah like I thought yeah
this this whole movie kind of uh dealt
in the gray or just the mud of of
everything because yeah I mean you know
you're with uh American soldiers we are
Americans watching this so like there is
a certain subconscious just like oh yeah
you know like the these are the good
guys and the Germans are the bad guys
and like certainly you know there's
nothing uh uh um what's the opposite of
reprehend you know like the Nazi
ideology is completely reprehensible um
but you know it does speak to the fact
that there are all these you know
ideologies and strategies and all this
stuff kind of hovering in a cloud above
you but when you're there on the ground
you know and you're limited to just you
know the people next to you and the gun
in your
hands yeah it's like you can prze about
you know morality and what war is but I
think at a certain point I think what
this movie seeks to kind of give to you
is that experience that like I don't
know goodness and Badness and all sorts
of things are kind of stories you tell
yourself to get through the the trauma
of it all cuz like watching this you
know it's like you've got this character
uh in Bible you know who is you know
obviously the most religious character
but but but by proxy is keeping them all
you know uh he's bringing at least that
element to the whole team and you get
the sense that like aside from him I
don't really think these guys are
religious or care about the concept of
God even but it's not even about that at
a certain point it's like or when
they're saying like best job in the
world you know or whatever that that
thing they kept repeating was morale it
is about morale and it's like all we can
do is just convince oursel like there
was so much great acting because what I
loved was was so many moments were
filled with these you know the these
words these these you know sentiments
and things that appear one way on face
value but when you look at the faces and
you look at the body language you can
feel what they're really saying that
they can't say because to say it in
plain terms would probably be too much
and probably break down that emotional
wall yeah so yeah it's like I I I I
thought this was really fascinating
because obviously David a you know from
his most uh respected work is clearly
you know skilled at bringing empathy to
people in the harsher positions in life
I mean we've seen him do a lot of
gangster and cop related stuff so that's
obviously flirting on the line and this
is sort of like a global geopolitical
version of that essentially you just
have Waring Clans essentially and so
this is actually kind of a great I think
kind of Peace for him because it really
speaks to the empathy that I think you
know whenever I hear David a or you know
speak or shoot a sentiment out there
like I get the sense that he is a
thoughtful and a compassionate
empathetic guy who also is very aware of
the harshness that exists in the world
and the places in which there is no easy
answer to right and wrong and the ways
in which you know you might have to in
some way collaborate with a person who
otherwise is sort of reprehensible and
you would never want to know otherwise
and so this I thought really
skillfully you know depicted in what
feels like very real time and what feels
kind of it it it had the right scope
because you you meet you know Brad Pit
and then you meet the team and then you
meet uh uh Logan meet Norman and machine
yeah it's like you meet Dad you meet the
family and then you meet us essentially
or or the eyeline you know for us you
know to sympathize the most with and to
kind of go through this right of passage
alongside this horrific but at the time
especially you know pretty common right
of passage and yeah like the way in
which you're at first sort of you know
put at odds with Brad Pit and you're
like come on man like gez like take it
easy you but very quickly you see like I
get what he's doing though and I get
that it's not only about him and Norman
it's about the I'm helping you not only
survive this situation of War but also
the situation of the people around us
that we have to be uh you know bonded to
in order to get through this and to
complete our mission and there were so
many times like Brad P performance like
there's so much in what he's doing that
feels clear even though it is unsaid
where I I just con constantly got the
sense of like I see myself in this kid I
know exactly what he's going through I
cannot afford to engage with him and
probably don't even have the the means
in this position to engage with him in a
truly compassionate way but what I can
do is really protect his transition Into
the Depths that we are about to Traverse
yeah for sure I mean and just adding to
that like I was frustrated when Brad Pit
was like holding the gun to him and even
though obviously as a Jew like obviously
I wanted to lead it as many SS Nazis as
possible in this time period of course
but like it's frustrating to to see like
him taking away that innocence of Norman
but at the same time it's like this is
not an innocent place that they're in
right now this is a war and you know in
order for them and the team to survive
like he's got to put Norman in a
hardened state of mind and in a Harden
place and the journey we go through with
Norman getting to that place I just
thought it was such an amazing journey
and Arc that we go through with his
character uh and at the same time I just
I feel so bad cuz he didn't even want to
be there and obviously I'm not saying
I'm not saying the other guys wanted to
be there although especially especially
yeah for sure um so it was uh you know
quite and Logan lurman I haven't seen
too many yeah he's a really great actor
I haven't really I haven't watched pery
Jackson or many other of his uh
performances but I really thought he did
such a phenomenal job uh like you said
just breaking down barriers with his
Expressions uh his facial reactions I
thought he did such a phenomenal job and
like he really is the audience in this
film he represents us and this is a lot
like kind of how we would react of being
thrust into such a crazy situation and
you know I felt that vulnerability
through him and also too on the same
point of Brad Pit yeah he's got to be
the hardened dad at points but also too
he becomes the the sympathetic mother at
some points too like you can feel the
vulnerable side that he feels towards
Norman too um and I appreciated those
delicate moments that he felt like he
loved Norman and I I love those moments
where those delicate situations that he
felt and that he had with nor and like I
really love and I thought David a was
really able to balance those moments uh
you know like again like you said in
transitioning him into what he needed
him to become because at the end of the
day yeah he's got to get him ready for
the situations that they're in but also
too like his life and the lives of his
the team members and everyone else that
are fighting around him they're in each
other's hands totally yeah and and and
you know War daddy seems to exist as
this intermediary between both
sensibilities because he can certainly
be he can certainly have that blood lust
and that Detachment that you sort of
need but yeah he's not fully detached
from what it feels like he's probably
just lost because like he says that
thing about like this is my home like
you know clearly he wouldn't be as
gotten as far as he has and be as good
this says that thing about like you know
we're one of the few squadrons or little
battalions like this who's like stayed
together kept together and has been
doing this for a minute now and so yeah
no yeah and so like it's a it's a
fascinating array of emotional tones and
you only get it's like I I really like
the way that this played out because you
you feel like you're joining even though
it has these very still and very poised
bookends these very sort of uh uh uh you
know kind of sculpted isn't the right
word exactly but yeah these very
deliberate book ends that then sort of
just give way to action that just keeps
going like there's this felt almost like
watching something like a 1917 or
something like that where you know that
movie the whole conceit is like it's one
long take so to speak it's played off as
one long take it's very immediate you're
in the real time and this isn't fully
real time but this did feel a lot like
that and this restricted you in the
sense that you're almost always with one
of them one of this core you know one of
the crew of The Fury is who you're
always kind of with and so it's like it
has this
narrow view not in a not in a a bad way
or as a slight but it has this sort of
focus that keeps things very contained
to this place in time you're not hopping
around a lot of places you're not you
know zooming very far out and I think
that enhances the perspective of
everything and enhances the you know
like in the early parts of the movie
you're spending so much time just moving
around and and you know on this Caravan
and like it's muddy and damp and and
just unpleasant all around for everybody
and it's kind of like everyone's just
bored we're just moving and then we come
into a little Township and then there's
a firefight but then we get this moment
of respit and you know then there's that
little like that that whole scene in the
in the house with um the the woman and
Emma like was so tense because obviously
you know where these things could head
because you have a bunch of you know
soldiers repressed and you know having a
break for a minute um but that I thought
was a a terrific example of like I love
the way this used scenes because it
never really took breaks to have like a
lot of cliche you know here's your
requisite like oh my girl back home kind
of scene not to slight other movies and
the approach that other war movies take
but this had like two very distinct
prolonged scenes you had the scene
upstairs and then you had the scene um
later on uh uh uh there's a there's a
scene later on when they finally start
to bond with him and everything and like
the actual will five of them really come
together yeah yeah I think it's that
scene like there were a couple scenes
that really struck me in the moment of
like oh we're just letting this scene be
what it is and and I like that because
it really did feel like there's not a
break you never really get to pull your
head out of this and even in the brief
moments you know where you are taken
away from it you know it's it's still
right around the corner it still you
know could Ambush you at any second you
know and uh and yeah it's just like the
sense of perspective and the portrait of
that's the thing is like yeah there are
the broad Strokes of who the good and
bad guys are and even though like yeah
you know when we're dealing with Nazis
there's not a lot of you know moral
wiggle room there but there is still
that essence of when you're just out
here on the battlefield and you're kind
of all that stuff is upstairs on the
table of the politicians you do feel
just the the horrific nature of humanity
all around even if you know aren't like
oh these precious nazzi you know like at
the same time you know this is this sort
of harsh awful thing yeah that is like
made necessary and that people just got
to deal with and and yeah like both a
Coming of Age story but also you know
for uh the brag pick character like you
know the end of you know like coming to
a place of rest and you know completing
the mission so to speak but even the
mission is just another in a long
sequence of battles and things are just
going to move on you know it's I did uh
appreciate too that moment at the end
where Norman or machine was hiding in
the dirt and then that one Nazi Soldier
saw him and decided not because again
it's like hey there's other you know
from their perspective there's other
soldiers on their side who kind of were
like Norman as well not everyone is
extremely evil like a lot of them are
but not ex not everyone you know wants
to be in war and wants to you know
Murder and annihilate everyone so I
appreciate that one you know uh you know
semblance of David a just trying to say
hey not everyone is extremely evil and
wants to to kill and also too another
thing I do want to say too we talk about
all these great characters that we got
from Brad Pit John Bernthal shy La buff
Michael Peña and Logan lurman I thought
the tank itself was an actual character
and just like and and as we pulled away
from the tank like seeing it just laying
it was kind of like you know we were we
lost someone there in it in its own
right and uh it's like a hor like it's
like the horse almost you know like and
and the way that they characterize it by
constantly having the barrel with the
name poking into frame and like the way
they used that like I was I was quite
impressed by this as a feat of like you
know again from from what I know about
David A's career from the things I've
seen thus far like I was legitimately
impressed by what he was able to do here
from both a writing and Direction
standpoint and every other department in
between like I was sitting there
marveling going like man how what must
this have been like to shoot and a movie
like this especially is an undertaking
and is going to be arduous no matter
what like I have to imagine that even if
you're probably not spending that much
on
locations in particular you have so many
just like no man's lands and
countrysides but just like the
undertaking of all the rest of it has to
be such they already make a bunch of you
know like comparisons to how like a film
crew is kind of like an army uh you know
and and this was one of those things
where yeah there's there's no glamour
but there are moments of beauty and
there's it doesn't feel like a fantasy
or like a Rah kind of thing you know
it's like there are those moments but
even when he's you know you know
screaming even when Machine by the end
is you know screaming like [__] you Nazi
bastard you know like even that stuff
still feels like part of the greater
theme of like this is in the moment it's
what you need to do to forget about all
the other things that are just going to
lock you up and and you know probably
get you dead and uh and yeah I just love
the gray with which this operated its
whole thing and then yeah having these
two you know really tense but also
tender centerpiece scenes where yeah
there's the one upstairs with the girls
and then there's the other scene with
everybody in the tank uh yeah just I
thought this managed to avoid feeling
cliche or like there's like too much you
know uh uh idealization or magic and
then when you get to that moment at the
end when the other Soldier is checking
under the tank and you can see the
wheels turning and then finally he's
caught up by the others and decides to
leave it's it's just the right at least
for me the right amount of that
peripheral magic that karmatic
inexplicable thing of like even though
you have been forced to learn past this
point that instinct serves you well and
I did think that yeah even though uh
Grady or whatever the John Bernthal
character's name was you know is like
the worst guy out of all of them and
that moment in there doesn't redeem him
it does like fully it does show you the
human that exists within and it does
speak to how harsh and and messy all of
this is and hey maybe this guy wouldn't
even be that good on a normal day
without all this trauma compounding but
still that little moment of like you
know I don't think any of us are good
but I think you're good I think you're a
good person and jokes aside after
watching this film and again like I said
I have have not seen too many David air
films but Jokes Aside after watching
this Ensemble piece I can have I
understand why Warner Brothers would
want to have David a do Suicide Squad
again this actually makes me now really
want to see I mean not that I didn't
before but it really does make me want
to see that uh just to get like his true
Vision if because he has said for many
years now that that was really his
version uh so but after watching this
like I said I I truly want to see that
film a lot more now because uh the the
few films we have seen together of David
SS uh from a writing perspective uh like
you said he just he knows how to compile
uh just human raw human emotion sympathy
and just I love his themes that he does
in his film so I like many of you I'm
not a very huge fan of the theatrical
cut of Suicide Squad so if that we we
don't need to flog that everybody knows
where everybody stands if we ever do get
that version I'd be very interested one
day uh because the other films of his
that I have seen I really enjoy so I'm
very curious that is to say not everyone
makes a perfect film every day of the
the week so I mean it could it could
also be a flawed film as well I don't
know but I this definitely it certainly
seems like something that would be much
more Soulful and thoughtful the only
point I'm making is this definitely
makes me more intrigued than David A's
uh sympathizing words that he gives us
every day on Twitter about that being
his his own film but uh I I again I
really enjoyed this uh very gritty
emotional uh just camaraderie take on
World War II I would yeah in a used to
seeing tank movies where like and
granted there's other kinds of combat
but you do have like that there's that
one especially you know prolong uh you
know gripping set piece where yeah they
are just F tank fighting on the ground
and they're losing left and right and
and yeah and like you know and something
like this I mean this seems I associate
David a the most with ground level you
know you know grungy crime movies which
those speak to me the most in terms of
like what suicides like watching
training day was like man the guy wrote
this what Suicide Squad could have been
but this also speaks to you know the
scope and the effect like you know this
is effects heavy in terms of just all
the and again it's harsh and it's hard
to look at but the Carnage and the
squibs and and and the way all that is
realized and the way that it is both
punctuated but also like super
normalized by the situation through the
depiction you know uh is yeah like this
this speaks to a filmmaker that I am
very excited to like see more from and
to dive into the works of and and it
gives me that sort of like this is just
another boost to the sort of like well
if David A's got some coming out I
probably want to at least check it out
you know well congrats jonald you're
going to see one of my films soon this
that's true well gang Fury we did it we
lived through this yes did quite
striking I think it will be on my mind
for for some time to come thank you
Andrew I'm glad we got to share this
together been bonded by fire we both got
a you know comment below what's our war
names that we have definitely
defin in life um but yeah thank you guys
so much for watching leave us your
thoughts down below and uh yeah just
just be well hug your loved ones and uh
we'll catch you on the next one much
love
h